a little reject nation I'm Greg Alba I'm
John Humphrey today we're going to do a
reaction to Iraq Iraq a video hopefully
cursed
Annabelle doll hunting since we saw
Annabelle figured yeah I'll listen to
the request here I love Rekha Rekha -
hey pitch and a shout out the jab Eco
1800 Kawai my brother guys if you don't
know this he has a awesome short film up
on his channel called raging bullish
aging bullets this black and white
comedy short is shot really well it's
really well done if you're a fan of
Raging Bull you really love it and he's
pledged on our patreon so I have to give
him a shout out brothers that's why Jake
Gyllenhaal and the total guard did that
movie based office - and this one played
you which one played Joey Natalie
Portman played me we sold the official a
no-go don't even eat it and once we come
so many women
[Music]
oh my god yes fictional reasoning you
just in that economic mess you've
amassed of [ __ ] trouble to be said to
you
[Music]
we're a family now about contrary Wall
Street okay so for the moment anyone was
looking to its eyes reading it really
well you look closely by the end block
is [ __ ] [ __ ] beds and all can sleep
on we're talking
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thanks Louisa usual hope obviously
that's wrong
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good good paranormal activity of the all
top
[Music]
[Music]
aramide everything that was you
these are the absolutely twice or the
Cubs I always different circles new
bloke which is having printed in words
jar congratulations you're choosing
print they're trying to print off a
hotel
I mean who whether it's Marnie Danny or
baby giant possibly make access those
more noise last night there's this
tricking this color just push it and we
take my [ __ ] foosball table on a
soccer star this is alcohol to dull this
is a movie prop we're going to set up
some time lashes overnight and prove
that this is all a sham this is the
sauna
Richard Chrysler Canada night vision
we're good it's on the box completely as
I show that she won't water here what's
wrong
this is cool now
[Music]
five times we're unveiling this way me
John I Cyrus you know half a mile from
Kumud old professor it's not water
someone pranking us what's the point in
this anyway this is a shot of something
Tuesday we're about an hour she really
is moving actually isn't it Gary is
Rafael again
I
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
did you say ground me and lowdown an
army of smells are needing Google damn
that's some of the best product
placement I've ever seen yeah I would
kill to do ones like that ass like you
make a whole thing out of the handle and
shorten some kind that was really well
done man
I like their blogs and they because I
know they're like usually intermittent
sketches but this felt more like a rack
a rack a sketch yeah most of it I'd say
oh yeah 90% of it felt like an actual
rack of record scratches nice to see
them go back to that one it's totally
natural in the house rekha format yeah
like I said in his paranormal activity
after aloud like this would start in a
normal environment and then become a
movie by the end oh yeah the way they
shot all the horse stuff was really well
done I would see the next deal with
horror elements affordable and stuff
before it and like making fun of tension
and suspense but what I love that of how
they do it is they really commit to it
oh yeah and I feel like these guys are
becoming more the more we get to hang
out with them in house abraço the more
they become three-dimensional characters
because that's the thing about their
sketches they're just kind of these two
dimensional character that works just
perfectly for Rocco Rocco sketch but
because you've had this time with house
of racket really get to know these guys
a little bit more it makes the responses
to things yes
when Annabelle disperses the chairs like
if you'd like to [ __ ] occasionally a
little Thomas like that or what makes us
like the human touches to Iraq Iraq
where we come through these house of
Rekha videos especially like you are
getting to do to see what life is like
in between the mayhem and then that just
a need to sketch like this where it's
like once it becomes a sketch time
you're like all but I know these guys
yeah I just thought it blew the day was
going fine I've killed it makes it feel
more like a purple more personalized web
series I think what they've been setting
out to do since they got this mansion
and putting the vlogs together and now
to them probably be doing live streaming
now I think this is all really cool what
they're aiming to do because at first I
was a little bit unsure how it would
feel about this I knew I was enjoying it
the more I watch of these the better
they keep getting like the editing is so
sharp and so on point it really does
feel like a full web series now is that
instead of just sketches we get twice a
month I wonder what they're like when
cameras are not rolling like for real no
real for real like when they're just
each one of them individually alone yeah
when no one is around or they always
give each other share there was hurting
each other
this is totally obvious because what
they're vlogging just 100% who they are
at all times will ever have a serious
moment but I met them they said that her
favorite types of films to watch are
like intense dramas not action film not
comedies I had a question about their
splicing of genre and I met them at
VidCon I was like what are they like
these horror movies or action movies you
really love watching like honestly we
don't really watch action movies or
horror films we watch like a lot of like
really sad jarama yeah yeah yeah I mean
I'm sure that there's an element you
know like having even just through this
experience I can imagine you know that
there's a certain element of truth in
the way they behave when a seed is that
it's real but I would imagine that it's
not just chaotic
like they don't live inside an episode
of Jackass I would imagine but maybe you
know half the time every I just don't
imagine that's all they really do cause
like the illusion is to make it look
like that like usually they get stuff
done yeah I mean you don't have a stress
is really edited together they expect me
even though it's simpler than that you
have a mansion together now they put out
these really well done videos so like
the other guys are Gen lazy and have fun
day they may actually work their asses
off and they're making that management
pay for itself
yeah by using the the heck out yeah you
know and I mean it like just from a
that's the cool thing about this
platform to it we've used that in our
own way when it comes to jumping between
these videos and sketches and stuff when
you can be you but then it's not you
it's like heightened and yeah sketch now
and yeah like how we don't do anywhere
near as many sketches of these yeah but
one day yeah that makes something like
this that much more fun engaging because
in their own way in a very different way
than we've ever used it but you know it
goes from normal routine into a sketch
flawlessly yeah great good job rack
inators and watch Annabelle creation
it's a pretty good movie check our
review on it guys subscribe to raka raka
you can subscribe to us and click on
notifications out I don't think they've
does do anything
YouTube's broken - on Humphrey on
Twitter
Instagram and patreon exists for a
reason
yeah find out why next week when I run
for governor of California okay